el miedo de que en un futuro
muchas tareas sean realizadas por máquinas
y no por seres humanos,
a juzgar por los grandes avances que se están logrando
en el campo de la inteligencia artificial y de la robótica.
Lo cierto es que habrá cambios importantes.
Lo que no está tan claro es cómo serán esos cambios.
La investigación que hice sugiere que el futuro
es inquietante e interesante.
La amenaza del desempleo tecnológico es real,
pero aun así es un problema con ventajas.
Y para explicar cómo llegué a esta conclusión,
quiero hablar de tres mitos
que en mi opinión hoy impiden tener un claro panorama
de este futuro automatizado.
Una imagen que solemos ver en las pantallas de TV,
en libros, en películas, en las crónicas diarias,
es la de un ejército de robots que llega a nuestro lugar de trabajo
con un solo objetivo:
desplazar a los seres humanos de sus trabajos.
A esto le llamo el "mito del Exterminador".
Es verdad, las máquinas desplazan a los humanos en tareas específicas.
Pero no solo los reemplazan,
también los complementan en otras tareas,
haciendo que ese trabajo sea más valioso e importante.
A veces las máquinas complementan a los humanos de manera directa,
aumentando la productividad y la eficiencia en una tarea particular.
Un taxista, por ejemplo, puede usar un GPS para orientarse en sitios desconocidos.
Un arquitecto puede usar un software específico
para diseñar edificios más grandes y complejos.
Pero el progreso tecnológico
no solo complementa al ser humano de manera directa.
También lo hace indirectamente, de dos maneras.
La primera es la siguiente: si concebimos la economía como una tarta,
el progreso tecnológico aumenta el tamaño de esa tarta.
A medida que la productividad aumenta, el ingreso sube y la demanda crece.
La tarta de Gran Bretaña, por ejemplo,
es más de 100 veces mayor que hace 300 años.
Así, quienes fueron desplazados de sus tareas en la viejo tarta
encontraron en la nueva tarta otras tareas para hacer.
Pero el progreso tecnológico no solo agranda la tarta,
sino que también cambia sus ingredientes.
Con el tiempo, la gente va cambiando la forma en que gasta su ingreso,
distribuyéndolo de otra manera entre los productos disponibles,
y desarrollando gustos por nuevos productos también.
Se crean nuevas industrias,
surgen nuevas tareas que realizar
y por lo tanto habrá nuevas funciones que cumplir.
Volvamos a la tarta de Gran Bretaña:
hace 300 años, la mayoría de la gente trabajaba en granjas;
hace 150 años, en fábricas;
y hoy, en oficinas.
De nuevo, quienes fueron desplazados de sus tareas en la vieja tarta
pudieron asumir tareas en la porción de la nueva tarta.
Los economistas llaman a estos efectos "complementariedades",
que es en realidad un término elegante para expresar la forma diferente
en que el progreso tecnológico puede ayudar a los humanos.
Resolver este mito del Exterminador
nos demostrará que hay dos fuerzas en juego:
por un lado, el reemplazo de mano de obra por máquinas,
que perjudica al trabajador,
y por el otro estas complementariedades, que hacen lo contrario.
Veamos el segundo mito,
que yo llamo "el mito de la inteligencia".
¿Qué tienen en común las siguientes tareas:
conducir un automóvil, hacer un diagnóstico médico
e identificar un pájaro con un rápido vistazo?
Pues bien, hasta hace muy poco los economistas expertos
consideraban que estas tareas no podían ser fácilmente automatizadas.
Sin embargo, hoy en día todas pueden automatizarse.
De hecho, las principales empresas automotrices
cuentan con programas de conducción autónoma.
Hay una infinidad de sistemas que pueden diagnosticar problemas médicos.
Y hasta hay una aplicación que puede identificar un pájaro
de un rápido vistazo.
Ahora bien, no es que los economistas hayan tenido mala suerte y nada más.
Se equivocaron,
y lo importante es por qué se equivocaron.
Se dejaron engañar por el mito de la inteligencia,
por creer que las máquinas debían copiar la manera
en que pensamos y razonamos para superarnos en rendimiento.
Cuando estos economistas decidieron averiguar
cuáles eran las tareas que las máquinas no podían hacer,
imaginaron que la única forma de automatizar un trabajo
era sentarse con un ser humano,
pedir que les expliquen cómo hacían el trabajo,
y luego tratar de plasmar esa explicación
en una serie de instrucciones que la máquina debía seguir.
En un punto, también se creía esto en el campo de la inteligencia artificial.
Lo sé porque Richard Susskind,
que es mi padre y mi coautor,
hizo su doctorado en la década de 1980
en la Universidad de Oxford,
sobre la inteligencia artificial en el derecho
y formó parte de la vanguardia.
Junto con el profesor Phillip Capper
y el editor de textos jurídicos Butterworths
desarrollaron un sistema de inteligencia artificial para juristas,
el primero disponible en el circuito comercial
a nivel mundial.
Este era el diseño de la pantalla de inicio.
Según él, un diseño muy atractivo para la época.
(Risas)
Nunca me convenció del todo.
Lo publicó en forma de dos discos flexibles,
en la época en que los discos flexibles eran flexibles en serio.
Y usó la misma técnica que los economistas:
sentarse con la abogada,
pedirle que explique cómo resolvía un problema legal,
y luego tratar de plasmar la explicación en una serie de reglas
que la máquina debía seguir.
En economía, si los seres humanos se pueden explicar de esta manera,
los trabajos se llaman rutinarios, y pueden ser automatizados.
Pero si las personas no se saben explicar,
los trabajos se llaman no rutinarios, y se los considera inviables.
Actualmente, esa distinción
entre trabajo rutinario y no rutinario está muy difundida.
Pensemos cuántas veces escuchamos
que las máquinas solo pueden hacer tareas predecibles o repetitivas,
basadas en reglas o con pautas bien definidas.
Son todos términos distintos para referirse a tareas rutinarias.
Recordemos los tres casos que mencioné al principio.
Son todos típicos casos de tareas no rutinarias.
Si preguntamos a una médica, por ejemplo, cómo hace un diagnóstico
nos dirá que se basa en algunas reglas intuitivas,
pero en definitiva le costaría.
Dirá que ese proceso requiere de creatividad, criterio e intuición.
Pero no es fácil articular todo esto
y por eso se creía que era muy difícil automatizar estas tareas.
Si un ser humano no sabe explicarse,
¿cómo diablos empezamos a escribir las instrucciones
para que una máquina las siga?
Hace 30 años, esta visión era correcta
pero hoy en día es cuestionable
y en el futuro perderá todo sustento.
Los avances en la capacidad de procesamiento y almacenamiento de datos
y en el diseño de algoritmos
indican que esta distinción entre lo rutinario y lo no rutinario
será cada vez menos útil.
Para ilustrarlo, volvamos al caso del médico que hace un diagnóstico.
A principio de año,
un equipo de investigadores de Stanford anunció el desarrollo de un sistema
que puede identificar si una mancha en la piel es cancerígena o no
con la misma precisión del diagnóstico de dermatólogos de prestigio.
¿Cómo funciona?
No intenta imitar el criterio ni la intuición de un médico.
No sabe ni entiende de medicina.
En cambio, ejecuta un algoritmo de reconocimiento de patrones
que recorre 129 450 casos previos,
y busca similitudes entre esos casos y la lesión específica en cuestión.
Realiza estas tareas de una manera no humana,
analizando los casos más probables,
que serían imposibles de revisar para cualquier médico en toda su vida.
No importó si ese ser humano,
si esa médica, no pudo explicar cómo había hecho la tarea.
Ahora bien, hay quienes tienen sus reparos
porque estas máquinas no están hechas a semejanza de un humano.
Como ejemplo, tomemos a Watson, la supercomputadora de IBM
que participó de un concurso en "Jeopardy!" en EE.UU. en 2011
y le ganó a dos campeones humanos en el programa.
Al día siguiente,
el periódico Wall Street Journal publicó un artículo del filósofo John Searle
titulado "Watson no sabe que ganó en 'Jeopardy!'"
Brillante y cierto.
Watson no gritó de felicidad.
No llamó a sus padres para contarles de su logro.
No fue al bar a tomar un trago.
El sistema no pretendía copiar la forma en que jugaban los participantes humanos,
pero no tenía importancia.
Aun así, les ganó.
Al resolver el mito de la inteligencia,
podemos ver que nuestro limitado conocimiento de la inteligencia humana,
de la manera en que pensamos y razonamos,
ya no es una limitación para la automatización
como lo era en el pasado.
Más aun, hemos visto que cuando estas máquinas
hacen tareas de un modo distinto al de los seres humanos,
no hay motivo para pensar
que lo que nosotros podemos hacer
sería una especie de punto máximo
de lo que estas máquinas llegarían a hacer en el futuro.
Veamos el tercer mito,
que yo llamo "el mito de la superioridad".
Suele decirse que quienes olvidan el lado útil del progreso tecnológico,
las complementariedades que mencioné,
están cayendo en lo que se denomina la falacia de la cantidad fija de trabajo.
Pues bien, el problema es que esta falacia es una falacia en sí misma;
por eso la llamo
la falacia de la falacia de la cantidad fija de trabajo.
Paso a explicarla.
La falacia de la cantidad fija de trabajo es un viejo concepto.
Un economista británico, David Schloss, le dio este nombre en 1892.
Quedó asombrado cuando una vez vio a un estibador
que había empezado a usar una máquina para hacer arandelas,
esos pequeños discos metálicos que mantienen apretados los tornillos.
Este estibador sentía culpa por aumentar su productividad.
Claro que casi siempre ocurre lo contrario:
sentimos culpa por no ser productivos,
por pasar demasiado tiempo en Facebook o Twitter en el trabajo.
Pero esta persona sentía culpa por ser más productiva,
y lo explicó diciendo: "Sé que estoy haciendo lo incorrecto;
le estoy quitando trabajo a otra persona".
En su visión, había una cantidad fija de trabajo
que debía dividirse entre él y sus compañeros,
y al usar una máquina para aumentar la producción
habría menos trabajo para sus compañeros.
Schloss vio el error.
La cantidad de trabajo no era fija.
Cuando este trabajador usara la máquina y aumentara su producción,
el precio de las arandelas caería, la demanda crecería,
surgiría la necesidad de hacer más arandelas,
y habría más trabajo para sus compañeros.
La cantidad de trabajo aumentaría.
Schloss le llamó a esto "la falacia de la cantidad fija de trabajo".
Actualmente se habla de esta falacia
para referirse al futuro de todos los trabajos.
No hay una cantidad fija de trabajo que deba dividirse
entre las personas y las máquinas.
Sí, es cierto que las máquinas sustituyen a los humanos
y así disminuye la cantidad de trabajo,
pero también los complementan
y la cantidad de trabajo aumenta y cambia.
Pero la falacia de esta falacia entraña un error:
es correcto pensar que el progreso tecnológico
aumenta la cantidad de trabajo.
Algunas tareas se valorizan, nuevas tareas aparecen.
Pero es incorrecto pensar que necesariamente los humanos
estaremos en mejores condiciones de hacer esas tareas.
Y este es "el mito de la superioridad".
Efectivamente, la cantidad de trabajo puede ser mayor y cambiar,
pero a medida que las máquinas se hacen más capaces,
es posible que asuman esa cantidad extra de trabajo.
El progreso tecnológico, más que complementar a los humanos,
complementa a las máquinas.
Para entenderlo, volvamos a la tarea de conducir un automóvil.
Hoy en día, los sistemas de GPS
nos complementan a los humanos de forma directa.
Nos hacen mejores conductores.
Pero en el futuro
el software desplazará a los humanos del asiento del conductor,
y estos sistemas de GPS, en lugar de complementar a los humanos,
simplemente harán que los vehículos sin piloto sean más eficientes,
y ayudarán a las máquinas.
O vayamos a las complementariedades indirectas que mencioné antes.
La tarta de la economía puede agrandarse,
pero a medida que las máquinas se hagan más eficientes,
es posible que haya mayor demanda de productos fabricados por máquinas
y no por humanos.
La tarta de la economía puede cambiar,
pero a medida que las máquinas se hagan más capaces,
es posible que estén mejor posicionadas para realizar las nuevas tareas.
En definitiva, la demanda de tareas no implica demanda de trabajo humano.
Los seres humanos se benefician únicamente
si se mantienen a la delantera en todas estas tareas complementadas,
pero a medida que las máquinas se hacen más capaces,
esas posibilidades se reducen.
Ahora bien, ¿qué nos enseñan estos tres mitos?
Resolver el mito del Exterminador
muestra que el futuro del trabajo depende del equilibrio entre dos fuerzas:
una, la sustitución de mano de obra por máquinas
--que perjudica al trabajador--
y la otra, las complementariedades
que hacen lo opuesto.
Y, hasta ahora, esta balanza se ha inclinado a favor de los humanos.
Resolver el mito de la inteligencia
muestra que esa primera fuerza, el reemplazo del trabajo por máquinas,
se está imponiendo.
Está claro que las máquinas no pueden hacer todo,
pero sí mucho más,
penetrando más aún en el terreno de las tareas hechas por nosotros.
Además, no hay motivo para pensar
que lo que los humanos podemos hacer hoy sería una especie de línea de llegada
y que las máquinas se detendrán tranquilamente en su avance
una vez que igualen la capacidad humana.
Ahora bien, nada de esto tiene importancia
mientras esos vientos favorables de la complementariedad
soplen con suficiente fuerza.
Pero resolver el mito de la superioridad
nos muestra que ese proceso de invasión de tareas
no solo robustece la fuerza de la sustitución del trabajo por máquinas
sino que también debilita esas útiles complementariedades.
Si reunimos estos tres mitos
podremos tener una idea de ese inquietante futuro.
Las máquinas siguen siendo cada vez más capaces,
invadiendo cada vez más las tareas realizadas por seres humanos,
robusteciendo la fuerza de la sustitución del trabajo por máquinas
y debilitando la fuerza de las complementariedades.
Y en un punto, la balanza se inclina a favor de las máquinas
más que de los seres humanos.
Este es el camino que hoy estamos transitando.
Y digo "camino" a propósito porque no creo que hayamos llegado,
pero no podemos negar que vamos en esa dirección.
Esto es lo inquietante.
Les diré ahora por qué considero que este es un problema con ventajas.
En casi toda la historia de la humanidad, el problema económico dominante ha sido
cómo hacer para que la tarta de la economía alcance para todos.
Vayamos a comienzos del primer siglo de nuestra era,
y veremos que si la tarta de la economía global
se dividiera en porciones iguales para todas las personas del mundo,
cada uno recibiría unos cientos de dólares.
Casi todas las personas vivían al borde de la línea de pobreza, o cerca.
Y si nos adelantamos mil años,
sigue siendo igual, en líneas generales.
Pero en los últimos cien años, la economía ha tomado vuelo.
Esas tartas de la economía se han disparado en tamaño.
El PIB mundial per cápita,
el valor actual de esas porciones individuales de la tarta,
es de unos USD 10 150.
Si la economía sigue creciendo al ritmo del 2 %,
nuestros hijos serán el doble de ricos que nosotros.
Y si continúa su crecimiento en un modesto 1 %,
nuestro nietos serán el doble de ricos que nosotros.
En líneas generales, hemos resuelto ese tradicional problema económico.
Ahora bien, si se produce el desempleo tecnológico,
será, curiosamente, un síntoma de ese éxito.
Habrá resuelto el problema de cómo agrandar la tarta,
pero creará otro:
cómo asegurarse de que todos reciban una porción.
Tal y como piensan otros economistas, resolver este problema no será fácil.
Actualmente, para la mayoría,
el trabajo es nuestro asiento a la mesa de la economía,
y en un mundo con menos trabajo o incluso sin trabajo,
no está claro cómo obtendrán su porción.
Mucho se ha debatido, por ejemplo,
sobre las distintas formas de ingreso básico universal
como una medida posible,
y se están realizando ensayos
en Estados Unidos, Finlandia y Kenia.
Este es el desafío colectivo que debemos enfrentar,
cómo hacer que esta prosperidad material generada por nuestro sistema económico
sea disfrutado por todos,
en un mundo donde el mecanismo tradicional de distribuir
las porciones de la tarta,
el trabajo que hace la gente,
se debilita y quizá desaparezca.
Resolver este problema nos obligará a pensar de otras maneras.
Habrá grandes desacuerdos sobre el camino a seguir,
pero es importante recordar que es mejor tener este problema
que el que acechó a nuestros ancestros durante siglos:
cómo hacer que esa tarta sea lo suficientemente grande.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)